three things that I disliked about
Insidious the red door and this one is
going to contain spoilers number one
that opening argument between Josh and
Dalton I thought it was way too over
dramatic and it honestly made me worried
that the rest of the movie was gonna
suck I don't think that ended up being
the case I think it did kind of settle
into a nice Groove there but that
opening argument just felt like too much
number two at least coming back at the
end so in Insidious Chapter 2 at least
talks about going to a place beyond the
further where souls are supposed to go
to but she came back to help them but
this movie takes place nine years later
so did she never go to the place beyond
the further or did she go there and
she's able to come back and if she's
able to come back then why didn't she
come back and help the family while they
were still in danger the whole
appearance with her at the end didn't
really make sense to me and I would have
been fine if they just had her appear in
the YouTube video in the middle of the
movie and number three the fact that
there's not really a resolution or
defeat of redface going into this movie
I kind of thought it was going to be the
last Insidious redface has been hanging
around for what 13 years now in our
world and in nine years in their world
and I feel like it just would have been
more satisfying if we got a conclusion
with him let me know what questions you
had about the movie in the comments